foreign
[Music]
people in East Ukraine are ordered to
vote on whether they should become part
of Russia or is it what they really want
[Music]
and imagine being on the same court as
your tennis Idol we meet the ball kids
who did I've got to know about Djokovic
thing behind me I've never seen him
alive so it's definitely something
really exciting
[Music]
hi we've got loads of info for you this
week and we've got a guess it's only
Joseph coylow the new children's
Laureate hello hey yeah we'll explain
later first Braden I've got a story for
you but is it true
[Music]
we're all worried about climate change
but one person has come up with an idea
to patch the problem up here's a plan to
refreeze both the North and South Poles
by
stratospheric aerosol injection
come again they would release sulfur
dioxide the same stuff that comes out of
volcanoes it would give shade from the
Sun and cool down the melting ice caps
to keep the polar bears and the Penguins
chill
what do you think is this fake news or
fact
[Music]
for many ukrainians around the world the
last few days have been a worrying time
Vladimir Putin the president of Russia
who ordered the invasion of Ukraine six
months ago ordered votes to take place
in parts of Ukraine that Russian troops
are occupying asking people if they want
their town or Village to remain in
Ukraine or become part of Russia a vote
like this is called a referendum
there were reports that Russian soldiers
would go into people's houses and
watching them make their choice so they
might not have voted how they wanted to
that's so scary most world leaders are
saying that the vote is illegal and that
the results shouldn't be trusted
[Music]
Zarina and her big sister vika came to
England because their city in Ukraine
was bombed
image
this makes me really angry when I
watching videos like that
all of these events which are taking
place here the majority of them are fake
they're just faking all of this I have a
friend from people who I know from this
territory than bus marupa lugansk dinesk
and nobody wants to be Russian we are
very very sad because it will be very
difficult to get back these territories
after this
as far as President Putin is concerned a
massive 15 of Ukraine will become part
of Russia and by saying these areas are
a part of Russia instead of Ukraine
President Putin is warning that no other
country should try and take them back as
it would be considered as an attack on
Russia did you see that President Putin
has given orders to 300 000 men to join
the Russian army to also fight in
Ukraine
many don't want to and there have been
cues at the border as people try and
leave
its Invasion into a free country and
after that I don't think they have a
right to do referendum elections or
something
People Under Pressure cannot decide
fairly
[Music]
hey Braden did you know that there were
over 39 theaters in London I mean they
certainly love plays in musicals then
don't they yeah and while many of us
love being in musicals shows at schools
or local drama groups we wondered what
it was like to actually be in a big
professional production so we sent an
FYI News Club member backstage
hi I'm joy and I love to sing so I'm
very excited that FYI has invited me
here today to go behind the scenes of
Frozen the musical
Let It Go the musical is based on the
movie about two sisters hi
hi I'm Casey and I'm the young Elsa and
I'm Elisa and I play Young art now come
on inside we'll show you around come on
wow this is where we get everything
ready before the show starts so we have
all of our dresses over here
this is the fix wrap question this is my
personal food yeah I'm really excited
and amazed to be here because like
normally only VIPs get to come here
[Music]
this is wardrobe Village wow
so this is where all the girls get
changed and over there just so over here
these are the Ensemble legs yeah this is
for the Summer Festival this is the
Queen's wig and down here these are the
hookah wigs
[Applause]
[Music]
how does it feel to be on Elsa and young
Anna it's like a dream come true really
yeah because I remember when I was
younger I really wanted to be a Disney
princess and a couple of years later my
dreamers completely come true it's an
amazing experience to be here what
advice would you give other young people
like yourselves if they wanted to get
into performing like you if you're
really into it then like join a club or
like a School drama club I just say be
resilient work hard you will get no's
but you will get those few yeses and if
you do get a no it's not because you're
not talented it just means that maybe
you didn't fit the role that they were
looking for if you're like nervous on
stage how do you beat your feelings
before the show I would take a deep
breath in and out and once I've said
some of my lines and sang some of the
songs then I feel fine yeah exactly the
same I don't feel as nervous as I did on
my first couple of shows
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you'd like to be an FY news club
reporter then get a teacher to set up an
FY news club at your school who knows
you might get exclusive access to
something too just head to our webpage
for more info first.news forward slash
FYI
still to come what's it like to give
Roger Federer his last tennis ball ever
[Music]
but first we've got the children's
Laureate in the studio
[Music]
hello Joseph welcome to FYI thanks for
having me it's great to be here well
thank you for your time so first of all
a massive congratulations but can you
please tell us what is the children's
Laureate well the children's Laureate is
a two-year role I'm following on from
press of the cow and other brilliant
writers and illustrators like Mallory
Blackman and Jacqueline Wilson and
basically the role of the Laureate is to
promote books and reading and how much
fun reading for pleasure can be and lots
of people might have seen your poetry
book overhead in a tower block yeah I've
got a new book coming out which is a
verse novel called The Boy Lost in the
Maze which follows on from an earlier
novel I did called the girl who became a
tree so it's kind of similar in tone so
what's it about the Boy Lost in the Maze
is about a modern day Londoner called
Theo who was searching for his
biological father but as he searches the
story becomes intermingled with this
Greek myth and as the reader reads the
story they can choose their own path it
does sound so cool but back to the
Laureate job what exactly do you have to
do well each lawyer makes the role their
own so being a poet I'm going to focus
on poetry and getting the whole nation
writing poems I mean it's a tough
challenge that really isn't it it's
going to be difficult I mean it's not
for everyone is it yeah you're quite
right A lot of people get turned off by
poetry and think it's really difficult
or not for them so I'll be releasing a
video which will show a really fun
creative way of getting involved with
poetry without it being too threatening
the first video that's going live on
National poetry day is all about the
environment and looking out your window
listening to the trees creaking and the
sounds of the environment to get you
started writing a poem and there's so
many different types of poems as well
yeah yeah like you've got Shakespeare
did loads of sonnets and then there's
funny limericks I even consider like
riddles and joke telling and songs and
lyrics as all coming under the umbrella
of poetry right so there's one thing
that we have to mention it's unmissable
it's the center of attention the medal
come on tell us about it this is my
medal it was pretty cool so I got this
medal on the 4th of July every Laureate
gets a medal it's silver and I'm making
the most of wearing it whilst I can't
wait to the shops anyway so I was
wondering if maybe you could tell us one
of your poems later on oh I'd love to
amazing that'd be amazing can't stop me
there have been a lot of tennis
retirements recently Serena Williams and
last weekend Roger Federer imagine
giving him his last ball well that was
these lucky ball kids jobs
[Music]
146 miles an hour
that's the speed of an average
professional players serve
would you be brave enough
I'm Shakira and I'm a bulkhead last
weekend Shakira Daisy Ollie and Tim were
watched by thousands of people as they
took on the job of a lifetime at one of
London's biggest ever tennis events the
labor cup is a big tournament which has
the top players in Europe against the
top players in the rest of the world and
they go head-to-head every year in a
different venue
the labor cup is different to all other
tournaments because it's players coming
together who normally play against each
other
it's amazing to be here as a ball kid
because you get to see the best of the
tennis as well as the coaching and the
face-to-face contact with the players
I've got a new back talk of it same
behind me
right now we've got Diego and we've got
Felix ogi the same training so it's
quite crazy to be able to be this close
to them for me it's like a dream country
earlier we spoke to a Novak Djokovic and
we asked him a few questions about his
favorite tournament which he said it was
Wimbledon which is amazing because he
was so friendly and really nice it's
just really really good to have the
privilege to be able to come here and be
on share the court with the great
players anyone was able to apply to
become a ball kid and after competing
against 450 hopefuls Shakira was one of
the lucky 24. being a bull kid means
that we have to be on court with the
players and we have to clean up the
walls as quickly as possible and the
other thing is just being like really
concentrated on what the players want
because you need to know when they won
the balls or not I'm really nervous but
all the practice today has really helped
to make me feel a lot more calm about it
well obviously we had some rolling
because that's like the main aspect of
being a ball kid so make sure the roles
are like nice and flat not bouncing
around and also working together in a
team because that's a key aspect of
working on the court so that there's no
mistakes and luckily there were no
mistakes for the final match the
highlight of the weekend when Federer
officially retired from professional
tennis
Ronnie I would do it all over again
my favorite player so I'll definitely be
quite upset to see him leave but luckily
for Tim and all the other ball kids they
were there for the last March and
because he's from Switzerland guess what
he got him to say everybody says Swiss
cheese
[Music]
earlier I told you about an idea to cool
down the North and South Pole to reverse
the effects of climate change but was it
fake news or fact
it's fact even though it would take
hundreds of thousands of flights
releasing even more carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere some scientists agree
this crazy idea might stop sea levels
Rising but it is just an idea
it's fake news to report it's actually
going to happen so be careful how you
pass on the story
[Music]
now October marks black history month a
month where schools make the special
effort of telling the stories of black
Lives who otherwise may be forgotten we
want to know who you're remembering so
please get in touch with us through our
webpage so Joseph what does Black
History Month mean to you well it means
a great deal because it's also about
representation and finding out those
forgotten histories when I was at school
I never saw or heard about a black
writer or any writers that looked a bit
like me until sixth form when a poet
called Gene been to Breeze from the
Caribbean came to my school she sat on
our school stage and that was the first
time I realized I could be a poet that
could be my job well we wanted to
highlight someone you've written a poem
about Rosa Parks in 1955 she made
history in America and around the world
for taking Action Against Racism
back then in the Southern States of
America there was something called
segregation laws which forced black
people to keep away from white people
there were separate areas in restaurants
schools and Cinemas it was the same on
buses when the white section was full
black people were expected to move out
of their seats
but on the 1st of December 1955 Rosa
Parks refused to give up a seat a civil
rights activist she wasn't just saying
no to giving up a seat she was saying no
to racism
but because of the law Rosa was arrested
and lost her job
the black people of rose's town were
tired of being treated differently
because of the color of their skin and
stopped using the buses for over a year
the Montgomery Bus Boycott made people
wake up to racism and that's why Rosa
Parks is still so important to Black
History Month absolutely I was surprised
to discover that there were many people
before Rosa Parks who had remained
Seated on a bus in protest including
Claudette Colvin who was only 15 years
old wow so I want to write a poem that
highlighted all of those people
including some of the young people that
helped make that change happen so I
really hope you guys enjoy the poem
thanks Joseph I mean I can't wait to
hear it well that's it for this week but
we'll leave you with Joseph's poem bye
not the first to sit
not the first to get arrested
not old she was 42 not tired just tired
of giving in
one of many unable to sit with the
Injustice of years
a rider on an Old Road walked by
millions on tired legs
these Riders fought a feat years in the
trudging of soul-worn protest
walked in frustrated miles over
Landscapes of lives one day became 13
months of continued mapping of
hitchhiking and carpools of walking and
tattered shoes because the bus wasn't
going anywhere they planned to go
[Music]